هناك يعني تحرك من بعض الدول الاوروبيه
التي اصبح اكثر وضوحا في الفتره الاخيره
مثلا السويد فنلندا الدنمارك تقترب من
الانضمام او تتحدث عن الانضمام لحلف
الناتو ماذا عن النمسا
موقع الجغرافي وتاريخ مختلف تماما
955 بعد ان غادر الحلفاء النمسا هو ذلك
الوقت اصبحنا واصبح ذلك حجر الاساسي
السياسي الخارجيه النمساويه 780% يدعمونا
بشده الحياه
عسكريه بحث
لا نريد
قوات او معسكرات اجنبيه
شكل
الدفاع عن القيم المشتركه ما بين الدول
بعض الدول الاوروبيه بعض الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي ترى انه المساعده العسكريه وتدخل
العسكري هو واحد من اذرع اذرعه الحفاظ او
من اذرعه الحفاظ على هذه القيم هل النمس
تشترك معهم في هذا الموقع
الاتحاد الاوروبي الدول 27 او الاعضاء
اسسنا ما يسمى
السلام او نحنا نساعد بذلك اوكرانيا ولكن
محققه لسنا من تلك الدول التي تقدم
الاسلحه والمعدات الفتاكه الى اوكرانيا
بما اننا احيائيين طاقه نونا ليس مسموح
لنا القيام بذلك ولكن لن نقدم مزيد
مساعدات الانسانيه كلها جزء من هذه
العمليه نحن جزء من هذه السياسه وندعمها